first at six tonight a high wind warning
going into place tomorrow morning here
in southern nevada wind gusts could
reach up to 70 miles per hour in parts
of the valley and we thank you for
joining us tonight at six o'clock i'm
sasha loftis 8 news now of course is on
your side with team coverage tonight
madison kimbrough is at decatur and
tropicana with how people are preparing
for those wins but first salahi romeo
joins us in the weather center with more
on what we can expect here sally sasha
from a high wind watch to a high wind
warning this is why we are showing you
this color red here representing how
strong these gusts will get up to 50 to
70 70 miles per hour it's going to
officially start monday morning at
around 11 a.m all the way to tuesday 3
a.m we want to also show you that blue
focusing on the lakes and definitely
moapa valley where you're also going to
be tracking those strongest but not as
strong as what southern clark county las
vegas you're going to be dealing with 40
to 55 miles per hour for you moapa the
lakes outside right now tracking those
70s it is very calm in terms of the wind
speeds nothing really impacting us we'll
eventually drop conditions a little bit
more around 11 p.m clear skies with
those 60s but coming up we'll talk more
about that strong spring storm system
bringing us that widespread high winds
to the entire region blowing dust
followed by those cooler conditions as
well and with weather on our minds we
want to make sure you stay safe and
prepare madison kimbrough spoke to
hardware store shoppers this afternoon
on what they plan to do she joins us
live near decatur and tropicana with the
latest madison
many people say with the high winds
expected for tomorrow getting the
essential items is a must with high wind
gusts of 55 to 70 miles per hour
expected to push through the valley the
potential for property damage is of high
concern simple tips such as securing
items outside of your home if you have
one make sure to place your car in your
garage and of course keep your pets
indoors at all times we spoke to some
hardware store shoppers on what they've
seen and how they plan to prepare
cover the glasses you know any
anything that would break and you know
fly away from the wind you know the
trees usually have to tie it down or
otherwise
it will fall
while it may be tempting to try to fix a
light or downed wire around your house
do not attempt to make any repairs until
the severe weather has calmed down we
reached out to nv energy for comment as
they issued an alert earlier this
morning about downed power lines stating
that crews will be ready to assess as
soon as possible reporting live madison
kimbrough live local now